There's a very popular, and
I thought, good movie out,
based on the play, which
is based on the novel
by Victor Hugo, Les Miserables.
And I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing it.
It means "the
miserable," for those
for whom it was not obvious.
And what I want to give
is a little bit of context
because in that
book, play, movie
there is an
attempted revolution.
And sometimes people
try to associate it
with the French Revolution.
But that is not depicting
the French Revolution
that people talk
about when they talk
about the French Revolution.
And so I thought I would
give a little bit of scaffold
of French history in the
late 1700s and all the way
through the mid-1800s to
give a little bit of context
on the matter.
So let's start off in 1789.
That's when you have
the French Revolution.
The First French
Revolution, we could
say, or the French Revolution,
which is the French Revolution
that people talk
about when they're
talking about the
French Revolution.
It was all about deposing
Louis XVI and his wife, Maria
Antoinette.
This is her body there.
I think she just
got guillotined.
This is her head.
It was very bloody revolution.
This is the storming of the
Bastille right over here.
And that starts the beginning
of the First Republic in France.
The First Republic.
So there were all these
dreams and aspirations
that France would now be
a country of the people.
Not too dissimilar
to the United States.
But revolutions are not so
easy, or so clean, or so fast.
And France had to go through
a long period of pain
before it could really establish
itself as a real republic.
But let's keep going on
further off in history.
Let me do that in
a different color.
I'll do the timeline in white.
So let's fast forward.
Let's fast forward to 1799.
This is when Napoleon
Bonaparte comes to power.
So when people talk
about Napoleon,
they are talking about
Napoleon Bonaparte.
We'll see that there
are other Napoleons.
But if people just say, hey,
Napoleon did this or that,
they're talking about
Napoleon Bonaparte.
So this is, Napoleon
comes to power.
Napoleon.
And he officially ends
the First Republic in 1804
because he declares
himself emperor.
But let's fast forward.
There's many videos on
the Khan Academy dealing
with the Napoleonic Wars
and the French Revolution.
But let's fast forward to 1815.
So let me do that
in white again.
So you get to 1815.
So let's see.
That was about 10 years.
I need to go about 16 years.
So that would put us at
1815 right over there.
1815 is, essentially,
Napoleon faces
his Waterloo, which was
literally at Waterloo.
That's why people talk
about facing your Waterloo.
So he was banished for
a little bit to Elba.
He was able to come back.
He had 100, actually
111 days in power.
But then he was
finally defeated.
And then he was
finally put into exile
at Saint Helena, where he died.
In 1815, you essentially
have the restoration
of the Bourbon monarchy.
So Louis XVI's younger
brother comes to power.
And they call him Louis XVIII.
So this is Louis XVIII, which
raises a very good question--
What happened to Louis XVII?
Louis XVII was
Louis XVI's son, who
died in prison at the age of 10
in 1795 during the Revolution
or during the revolutionary
period, I guess we could say.
So this right over here.
This right over here.
Napoleon ends -- let me draw.
This is Napoleon's-- let me do
this in the same color I did
Napoleon in.
So 1799 to, actually, 1814 is
when Napoleon's reign ended
but then he came back
for a little bit.
So I'll draw a little bit
of a dotted line here.
A little dotted line.
And then 1814 was the
formal restoration
of the Bourbon monarchy.
And, but of course, Napoleon
comes back a little bit.
But after Waterloo, it's
really firmly established.
So you have the restoration
of the Bourbon monarchy.
So this is Louis the XVIII.
And then in 1824 he dies.
And he dies childless.
1824.
So let's see.
It's about nine years.
So that will put us
about right over there.
1824.
He dies childless.
And so his younger brother,
Charles X comes to power.
So then you have
Charles X. Charles.
I'll do all the
Bourbons in purple.
Charles X. And this is
Charles X right over here.
And so let's go a little bit
further off into history.
You fast forward
all the way to 1830.
You fast forward to 1830.
A lot of discontent.
And now you have the
Second French Revolution.
You might say, oh
hey, this must be
what Les Miserables
is all about.
No, we're not there yet.
Les Mis is not about the
Second French Revolution,
sometimes called
the July Revolution.
July Revolution.
And this revolution actually
did not-- it was successful--
but it did not establish
a republic at this point.
It instead installed--
and this whole time there
was a liberalization.
The monarchy, even when
it was put in power,
had a gradual decline in
how much power it had.
But after the July Revolution,
they put in Charles X's cousin.
Charles X's cousin who
was the Duke of Orleans.
Who was this guy, this
guy right over here.
Louis Philippe I. So
let me write that.
So this is Louis Philippe I.
And so you're saying,
Sal, you started off
this video talking
about Les Mis.
You haven't mentioned
Les Mis yet.
Give me a little bit of context.
So now I will give you context.
So if you watch the movie, it
starts off with Jean Valjean.
He's at a shipping
place where they're
repairing ships of some sort.
That was in 1815 after Waterloo.
So it was under
Louis XVIII's regime.
So that's right over here.
Let me see where the
start of the movie.
The start of the movie
is right about there.
And then the real climax of the
movie, which is this rebellion.
There's these barricades
being set up in Paris.
You have all these
young idealistic folks
who are trying to
overthrow the government.
This does not happen until 1832.
This is 1832.
I'll do it right over here.
1832.
And what catalyzed
that-- there were
several things that
was catalyzing that.
And, actually, most
revolutions are
catalyzed by just
economic discontent.
If people are rich, and
happy, and have jobs,
and aren't getting
sick, most people
aren't in the mood to revolt.
But in 1832, as
you could imagine,
the economic situation
was not good.
There was also a very
nasty outbreak of cholera.
And what really catalyzed
the events in Les Mis,
and they even refer
to it in the movie,
is the death of this
chap right over here.
Jean Maximilien Lamarque.
Let me write the name down.
Jean Maximilien--
and I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing it-- Lamarque.
And he dies in June of 1832.
And he was very sympathetic
to the plight of the poor,
to the plight of the common man.
And the average folks
said, hey look, he's
our guy in government.
And he had an influential
role in government.
When he died, they
were like, look,
we don't have anybody else
in a high position who
can speak for us.
Let's use his funeral as
a catalyst for revolt.
And you saw that happening
in the movie Les Mis.
So Les Mis, that
climactic moment,
that is the June
Rebellion of 1832.
And it's not-- you don't have
to have amazing comprehension
of watching movies to realize
that this was unsuccessful.
So this right here, didn't work.
Didn't work.
If it did work,
It might have been
called the Third
French Revolution.
But it was not.
It was an unsuccessful
revolution
or unsuccessful
rebellion, really.
And it was that Victor
Hugo observed it.
And that's why he's able to
recount it in so much detail.
The barricading,
the young people,
the shooting in the
streets, all the rest.
So this is a little
bit of review.
When people talk about
the French Revolution,
they're usually talking
about the French Revolution.
1789.
Begins to establish
the First Republic.
It was a successful revolution.
The Second French Revolution.
This is the July Revolution.
This is in 1830.
This puts into power Louis
Philippe I, the person
that they're trying to
overthrow in Les Mis.
And they don't establish the
Second Republic after this.
For the Second Republic,
we have to go all the way
to the revolution
of-- let me make
sure I can scroll properly.
Go all the way.
So let me continue my timeline.
So this is Louis
Philippe to go 18 years.
18 years to 1848 where you have
the Third French Revolution,
which leads to the popular
election of Napoleon
Bonaparte's nephew.
Napoleon Bonaparte's nephew.
Louis Napoleon Bonaparte.
This guy right over here.
But France is still not done.
It still can't establish itself
as a long-lasting republic.
In 1851, this character
declares himself emperor.
So 1851, he too declares
himself emperor.
And France is not finally
freed of kings and emperors
until 1870.
So let's do this run all the
way to 1870 where France,
essentially, loses the
Franco-Prussian War.
And this character, this
character right over here,
is deposed.
And you have the establishment
of the Third French Republic.